hello everyone welcome back to comic con
2022. i've got the entire team behind
vampire academy with me right now hello
congratulations thank you
thank you thank you all right so we are
going to dig into the show but julie i'm
asking you a selfish question first
because i am one of the world's biggest
scream fans and i know you worked on
scream 2 back in the day so even though
that was so long ago and you've had so
much experience since is there anything
that you picked up on that set you still
find influencing your work as a producer
today absolutely two things and i'll
tell you the first then you tell me from
here the second otherwise i might be
talking too long but the one thing i
learned from wes craven who um i started
as his assistant on the movie screen and
then worked for him during scream two is
that wes really believes that your crew
and the people making your project are
your community and they are to be
cherished and protected and they are to
be brought along from job to job um and
they are to be invited to your table and
your you know thanksgiving and and that
it is if we're going to work this hard
and put as much as we have into this art
and this commerce like why not why not
hold each other close and and be good
people i love that i think every single
person out there should apply that to
their project all right now for the
reason we actually are here julie you
obviously have a good deal of experience
making vampire series so
is there any particular thing about the
way you go about making these shows that
stayed consistent from vampire diaries
to here but then also what is something
specific about vampire academy that
called for you to do something new i
would say the thing that is most
consistent about the way i personally
tell stories um
vampire stories specifically is and it's
controversial for true lovers of genre
and horror but i don't approach the
story uh as a genre story i don't
approach it as horror i don't approach
it as anything other than what it is
thematically and emotionally in its
purest form which in um you know vampire
diaries was about you know trying to
survive a deep grief and in uh the
originals was about trying to you know
recover uh and repair the scars of of
abuse and child and a dysfunctional
broken family legacies it's about
wanting to you know um
if you looked at as an outsider how can
you find the power within that and
actually grow into your own hero
and vampire academy is very much
uh what it means to
bond together with those you love the
most uh and then
make the change you want to see in the
world i love that answer so so much so
marguerite for you now i've really
enjoyed seeing the evolution of your
career from actor to like full producing
force and writing right now so was that
something you always knew that you were
drawn to or is there anything particular
about vampire diaries that sparked that
interest in you you know what i always
had written but i was as julie calls me
i was a secret writer because i'd always
sort of followed the flow of of my
career and i was happily and luckily
acting and it was keeping me busy but i
was always writing and then when i moved
to l.a
some two of my best friends were liz
siglar and this woman and they were two
of the greatest champions and saying
you're a writer too let's let's let's do
what we can with this and they were so
supportive so i really got very lucky
these women were kind and good to me so
they helped me see this world as a
possibility because i you know i lived
in new york i thought of plays and stuff
i was like oh writing for tv is like
being able to explore deeply these
characters over time it was so
satisfying to me so it was a wonderful
transition um and as far as vampires i
too
as a
not a super
genre person except that
for the for what it gives us i mean i
love vampers who doesn't love a vampire
but it gives us the ability to tell a
story and metaphor that sometimes is not
as easy to tell in a certain kind of
just raw truth and you can you can find
deeper places and people can reach to
that story and find places in themselves
that are sometimes harder to reach when
stuff is just you know it's not like
reading a newspaper and talking about
some issues it's actually being able to
experience them emotionally through
these beautiful characters that's what i
love about genres so so much there's so
many things that i've been able to
process through genre storytelling that
i can't just in my everyday life and
it's incredible it's why we need stories
like this all right so
to find a more unique way to tap into
all of your characters here can you each
tell me what you think their greatest
asset is at the beginning of the show
something that you would put in your
back pocket and want to take with you
but then what is their biggest weakness
something that maybe they need to
overcome as season one progresses um i
would say for rose
her greatest uh asset strength and
[Music]
the same thing and that is her passion
it leads her to do stupid things it
leads her to do
wonderful things and it's kind of the
driving force
when it comes to all of her decisions
and particularly surrounding the ones
that she loves
good answers yeah i like it
oh blue chick from julie fleck oh my god
all right how about for alyssa
yeah this is actually such an
interesting conversation i had this
conversation with kieran and he actually
gave me this answer for lissa he was
like yeah
yeah
he did he was like you know i think i
think her compassion is her strength and
can be her downfall as well i mean i
think lisa sometimes might trust people
too much or almost go an extra mile when
she really can't anymore and i just
think it's something in her that she she
can't help it i mean she's just this
compassionate person and it's what makes
their friendship so strong too so
that's a great that is also a great
answer i don't know how i followed that
um
i think for christian i think his
greatest strength in the beginning is
his resilience and his independence i
mean if you put myself i know personally
in the shoes that he had to be put in i
don't think i'd come out as uh hopeful
as he did and i i'd say his greatest
weakness is
he built a lot of walls around himself
and he doesn't let a lot of people in
but throughout the show we get to see
him
meet certain people and have that be
broken down a little bit and i think
that's something beautiful to watch
don't mess this up man they're doing it
the pressure's on right um am i allowed
to say that the strength and weakness
are i like again like see like he said
with rose for me it was always dimitri's
devotion uh in the sense of whatever he
does he's committed to and i think at
the start we meet him
and that's a bit more rigid and
disciplined towards his work and in the
end his devotion to other things can
sort of lead him into underway from
himself which brings us to his questions
yeah you all nailed it a plus all around
i'm sorry they're making us look really
talented and smart just thank you thank
you
margaret and julie you can probably both
speak to this now can you tell us a
little bit about what you're trying to
do with this show to evolve the vampire
subgenre a little because it was a
different time when vampire diaries
first started and the audiences like
they want the same but they also want
something different and more modern so
how can we see that applied to this show
well it's funny because the way we
describe the show to people is that it
is both ancient and modern at the same
time you can have an ancient castle and
a burger stand down the street um and
that really applies to the way that
we've uh approached the the vampire lore
itself which of course we pulled
entirely from the books so we don't get
the credit for it but what rochelle mead
did in the book series was created this
really fascinating species a vampire
called moroi
which is essentially what we call sort
of the polite
vampire the clean the civilized the you
know the white tablecloth vampire the
dainty elegant and you know
unfortunately maybe a little bit too
safe a little bit too posh a little bit
too stuck in their ways a little bit
fancy
um but it's been fun because that really
is sort of a new take on that character
but that and that species but we also
get the strigoi who are this this fierce
primal almost zombie-esque
uh ferocious and terrifying vampires who
do feed on blood and will kill you and
will live forever because they are
difficult to kill so we get to kind of
have a cake and eat it too we get to pay
lip service to all the great terrifying
elements of the genre but also have this
kind of austere interesting
sophisticated version and of course it
all becomes a class you know uh allegory
for class
well yeah i mean that was what was so
appealing to reread those books now i
feel like now is the perfect time to
tell them because it's a class system
that is fraying at the edges and should
because it's incredibly unfair and so
these two young women are waking up to
that fact and saying wait a minute we
didn't sign on to this is this fair what
do we do about it and how it challenges
their friendships because they're
basically on you know the opposite side
of the tracks you know for lack of a
better term
and the other thing is in updating it we
were careful about certain things we
love these books we feel very passionate
about the books and want to stay true to
them but we you know we
didn't really want to have the
teacher-student relationship so rose and
dimitri he is uh not he's maybe a mentor
but not a teacher she's a little bit
more you know she's of age there's
there's a little bit of stuff we did
with that we're just being a little more
careful because we recognize the time
we're going to want to be i want to be
uh sensible about that
i love it those added layers that's what
keeps it on the mind well after just
experiencing the thrill in the moment i
can't wait to see more big
congratulations to you all everybody out
there keep an eye out for vampire
academy the series yeah
you